there has been one popular no dangerous
way of making money in coal country this
landscape is littered with small
abandoned illegal mines if the normal
mines feel unsafe and dicey these are
even worse but most of them like this
one are closed
Ukraine refuses to buy the separatist
coal no point in mining the coal down
here if there's no one to sell it to so
as bad as this looks people can't wait
to get back down yeah because it's the
only way to make money around here if
I've learned one thing it's that the men
here will take any risk and enter any
mine in order to feed their families
coal mining is in their blood where else
are people going to work only in mines
businesses aren't working the factories
are idle this is a mining region with
mining towns while the world focuses on
the human toll over 6000 dead the
economic toll is also enormous
if the war ends the reconstruction will
take years and cost billions of dollars
eastern Ukraine needs a Marshall Plan
it isn't clear who will foot the bill
what is clear is this separatist
government needs help the town of snitch
norias field commander doubles as the
mayor as lemon lawyer what's most
important now is industrial production
it's not shut down but it's working at
half capacity the big goal is to get it
working at full capacity but I wouldn't
let blood to hit on avoid many of the
mines were directly targeted in the
fighting this mines administrative
office was a battle zone but in the
grand scheme of things shot out windows
can be replaced some lines have it much
worse like this one which was partially
flooded leaving hundreds of people
without any work coal mines naturally
flood their pumps prevent that from
happening when the mines pumps lost
power they nearly lost the mind they'll
recover this one but somewhere around
half of the region's mines may have been
lost altogether bridges airports roads
and railways lie in shambles looks like
these cars to get pretty direct hit
mines have no way of getting their coal
to market the political problem persists
Russia's providing the region with gas
and observers say some coal has gone to
Russia but Ukraine isn't allowing the
coal to travel freely across the front
lines and that's got far-reaching
consequences this plant should provide
power for 2 million people but a bizarre
and ironic technical snag means the
plants in peril this is one of the
biggest power plants in all of the area
controlled by the separatists and
they've got two days worth of coal left
in their stockpiles why because the
grade of coal
it needs comes from the Ukrainian side
Ukraine's economic blockade of the
Donetsk People's Republic goes beyond
coal after Ukraine froze the separatist
region out of its financial system banks
cash machines and credit cards don't
work all state services salaries and
Pensions were cut off in November a
meager pension of a couple of dollars a
day can be the difference between life
and death
the lines are getting longer at the soup
kitchen in snooze noia
but these people are not homeless
ordinary folk need this food to survive
war means tens of thousands of people
now depend on handouts I would like here
Stalag ahjumma chenko runs this place
she sees the elderly families even
miners who are getting paid but people
are now not living
they just survive it people are close to
starvation even a bowl of soup is
becoming a luxury prices in Ukraine are
rising faster than anywhere else in the
world other than Venezuela Alba says the
supplies in her kitchen come from one
place and one place only from Russia
from the Ukrainian side we get nothing
no attempts to how they've all forgotten
about us even though as you can see
there are no separatists or Russians
here which is a very product Russia
isn't only sending food to eastern
Ukraine for showing up in person and
making a spectacle of it alongside a
convoy of humanitarian aid a Russian
official tells reporters it's there on
the personal orders of the Russian
president state TV reporters broadcast
the message and good deeds across Russia
in eastern Ukraine meanwhile this
official tells me America is sending
military advisors to the other side
humanitarian aid is humanitarian aid
food is food this isn't politics I think
you shouldn't mix them together
we're at a mind that's lost dozens of
its men in a tragic accident just days
before and we're tagging along as miners
unload 50 kilo bags of flour and sugar
this is a hearts and minds campaign
it's interesting in other years I've
been watching Russia this is one of the
most vivid examples of soft power I've
seen yet local official complains
Ukraine is blocking the flow of vital
goods to the separatists
for the record Ukraine says their offers
of aid will reject it with all the
weapons and troops Kiev says Russia's
providing to kill its people
Russian soft power is the epitome of
hypocrisy